We do not work isolated or in an individual way in order to make an exchange happen.
In general, we are groups, or we have groups of volunteers working together in a community.
Through those volunteers, we reach out to schools, we reach out to participants, and we reach out to families.
So all of them, at some point, work together and relate to each other.
We are more of a social movement, rather than just isolated people doing isolated things.
And this structure doesn't only happen in our way of working, it doesn't only happen here in the US.
It also happens in all of the countries where we operate, and where we have been operating during the past 60 years or more.
So, that is what makes AFS very unique and very special.
On behalf of the board of directors of AFS-USA, our national council, and staff of the organization,...
...I want to thank all and each of you during this National Volunteer Week.